hallo ihr lieben will machen heute ist
ganz verrücktes machen einen herzhaften
crêpes auflauf erst richtig gehört das
ist so ein bisschen was für entschied
denn das gebe ich zu also nichts
alltägliches aber es kann man sich doch
mal gönnen oder und wir machen jetzt
zuallererst die herzhaften krebs und
dafür benötigen wir milch außerdem mail
geschmolzene butter und etwas salz für
den crap teig werden jetzt alle zutaten
zusammen in einer großen schüssel mit
dem schneebesen verrührt die reihenfolge
ist vollkommen egal ich gebe jetzt
zuallererst ein rein außerdem mehl
verrühren das kurz glas und dann durch
die restlichen zutaten mit dazu
[Musik]
sobald sich dann alle zutaten
miteinander verbunden haben ist der
crêpes teig fertig und der ist ziemlich
flüssig so ist genau richtig ich habe
mir hier schon meinen kreisen
bereitgelegt mit ein bisschen back
transfer eingefettet und falls ihr das
nicht da hat es auch gar kein problem
nimmt einfach eine beschichtete pfanne
und es gebe ich immer eine kelle vom
teig hier drauf verteilt das schön und
dann warte ich sie pro seite circa zwei
minuten lang aus wer kennt nicht der
erste der wird immer hässlich oder
schreibt mir die kommentare egal ob
pfannkuchen oder krebs der erste gibt
immer irgendwie erfüllen oder waffeln
der erste klappt nie
[Musik]
unsere krebs sind jetzt fertig genau
acht stück in der anzahl und die gebe
ich jetzt kurz an die seite denn jetzt
zeige ich euch wie wir unsere soße
zubereiten und mit was für die krebs
füllen für die sauce benötigen wir
gemüsebrühe außerdem märchen könnt ihr
auch durch sahne ersetzen wenn ihr
möchtet butter und mehl an gewürzen salz
pfeffer wer mag scharfes paprikapulver
außerdem habe ich die kräuter der
provence und oregano dann habe ich zum
befüllen paprika in scheiben geschnitten
meist käse und wurst eurer wahl ich
hatte total lust genommen und später zum
überbacken noch etwas käse ich habe
jetzt die butter in einem topf erhitzt
und zwar auf mittlerer stufe damit sie
uns auch nicht anbrennt und jetzt gehen
wir ein schwung das mehl mit hinein
grünen das gut um und dann erhalten wir
eine mehlschwitze afrika 30 sekunden
gehen in einem strahl unsere gemüsebrühe
mit hinz und rühren dabei ständig um
[Musik]
als nächstes gehen wir die milch mit
hinein dann fehlen uns nur noch die
gewürze
dann lassen wir das ganze einmal
aufkochen und dann ist sie so auch schon
fertig
[Musik]
unsere würzigen soße gebe ich jetzt an
die seite die benötigen wir nämlich
später erst wieder und ich zeige euch
jetzt ganz kurz die wir die schönen
crêpes taschen gefüllt werden
ich habe mir jetzt alles bereit gelegt
und werde jetzt zuallererst meine krebs
ein bisschen mit der sauce befeuchten
gas und zwei esslöffel damit hier auch
nochmal ein bisschen geschmack reinkommt
ansonsten gebe ich jetzt hier rein
einmal käse dann nämlich eine ganze
scheibe halbierte gibt die in die mitte
und unsere wurst und hier könnt ihr
wirklich flexibel sein also wenn ihr zum
beispiel andere gemüsesorten haben
möchtet gibt sie gerne mit dazu wir
haben uns jetzt heute für mais und
paprika entschieden
dann gebe ich das auch noch darauf
gerade so 1 s entschuldigung einen
teelöffel dann klappen wir das einmal um
von beiden seiten dann noch mal von oben
und von unten und umsatz höchstes
päckchen geht jetzt in die auflaufform
und so werden wir dieser anordnung
richtig schön eng also richtig schön
zusammenschieben und wir machen so
weiter bis alle krebs aufgebraucht sind
[Musik]
minecraft taschen sind fertig okay ist
166 geworden zwei habe ich noch übrig
eine auflaufform war leider nicht groß
genug
aber ich merke schon die ganze zeit wie
du dich france haben sagt draufstehen
dass sie sich so ist auf jeden fall gebe
ich jetzt noch die restliche soße
darüber anschließend werden wir das mit
käse bestreuen und dann in den ofen
geben
[Musik]
unser clip auflauf kommt jetzt in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 180 grad ober
und unterhitze so 15 bis 20 minuten
schaut einfach dass der käse in goldgelb
ist und dann könnte ihn sofort servieren
und fertig ist und seit cap auf lauft
also ich könnte krebs immer nur mit
nutella wird sich dann irgendwann
gedacht okay krebs geht doch auch
herzhaft es muss nicht immer süß sein
und falls euch das rezept gefällt dann
macht es gerne nach hier unten in der
infobox stehen die genauen mengenangaben
ich freue mich über eure fotos mit dem
hashtag s kitchen auf instagram und wenn
ihr mit dort noch nicht folgt dann geht
es schnell war denn da seid ihr immer
auf dem aktuellsten stand und ihr
erfahrt immer was hier als nächstes
passiert ansonsten freue ich mich wenn
ihr dieses video in dem sie nach oben
gibt wenn ihr meinen kann kostenlos
abonniert dann verpasst ja auch nicht
mehr und dann sehen wir uns beim
nächsten mal und ich sage nicht ich
sondern auf wiedersehen genau ich sage
uns much ist aber ich will euch doch
wieder sehen also auf wiedersehen
[Musik]